خط المواجهة في معركة أوروبا ضد
الفيروس التاجي مع جنودها في
سباق مع الزمن الذي فقده حتى الآن
مستشفيات شمال إيطاليا مثل
هذا المستشفى في كريمونا الذي يئن
تحت وطأة الضغط.  أنجيلو بان يظهر لنا
حول غرف العمليات التي
تحولت الآن إلى
وحدات مؤقتة للعناية المركزة ، حيث استخدم المركز الدولي نفسه
غارقًا في العدد الهائل
لمرضى كوفات 19 بالإضافة إلى النقص في الأسرة
وأجهزة التنفس الصناعي التي مرض الأطباء
أنفسهم د.  حصل بان على يوم عطلة واحد
في الأسابيع الستة الماضية
، يقول إن الحبس التام هو الأمل الوحيد في العالم ،
لذا تستمر العدوى في
الانتشار ورسالته من خط المواجهة
إلى العالم الخارجي
[موسيقى]
اختبار اختبار ميليسا بيل على شبكة سي إن إن يقول من ولكن  قد
يستغرق الأمر أيامًا في المختبر حتى الآن في أوكسفورد إنجلترا
، يعتقدون أنهم قد أجروا
اختبارًا يعتمد على لون نمط الحمل يمكن استخدامه في أي
مكان للمواد الخام التي تكلف حوالي
خمسة وعشرين دولارًا الآن هذه ليست
مستشفى بالطبع وهذه ليست
معقمة ولكن  الأمل هو أن تكون قادرًا
على أخذ عينة من أنف شخص ما
ووضعها في أنبوب اختبار ثم
اختبارها لمدة نصف ساعة فقط في جامعة أكسفورد ،
ولا يمكنهم اختبارها لأنها
قد تلوث مختبرهم
ولكنهم يعملون على  عينة تحكم سلبية وإيجابية
وكان لها السبق
منذ ستة أسابيع بمساعدة
الأكاديميين الشركاء في الصين هنا ، يضيف
عينة تحكم إيجابية إلى مزيجهم الخاص
من المواد الكيميائية والإنزيمات قبل أن يتدخل أحد
الزملاء لوقف العبور.
تلوث تضعه في
آلة تسخن كلتا العينتين إلى 65 درجة
مئوية أو 150 فهرنهايت لمدة 30
دقيقة ، ثم يتم الانتهاء من اللون الوردي
والأصفر الجيد سيء ، وهناك سباق مع
الوقت هنا أيضًا يحتاجون إلى تجارب سريرية
لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا
ثم الموافقة التنظيمية على ذلك.  الإنتاج السريع
ثم الضخم في منشآت نظيفة
يأملون على الرغم من أن ذلك قد يكون
ممكنًا في غضون أسبوعين إلى أربعة أسابيع ،
لا شيء يعمل حتى يعمل
وقد يكون هناك عجز هنا ولكن هناك
مكافأة أخرى أيضًا في الوقت الحالي
نحاول دفعها إلى أن كل شيء يحتاج
إلى  أن يكون من
قبل أشخاص محترفين في المستشفى
ولكننا نقوم بذلك مثل القيام ببعض
التطوير على أمل كامل أنه يمكننا
الحصول على مجموعة إيزي كاب التي لا يستطيع الأشخاص
استخدامها ، يحتاج الاختبار إلى درجة حرارة يمكن لأي شخص
إنشاؤها باستخدام الماء في المنزل لذلك
جزء واحد بارد  جزئين يغليان ساخنين
تمامًا ثم نفتح الاختبار
ونضع الغطاء على مجموعات تدعي
أنها أسرع ولكن هذا بسيط
ويمكن استخدامه في أي مكان حتى  أقل من 25 دولارًا
إذا تم إنتاجه بكميات كبيرة من الوضوح السريع والرخيص
في وقت كان فيه عدم اليقين يحكم
نيك باتون والش سي إن إن أكسفورد
أعراضنا المختلفة التي نسمع عنها الآن
من الأطباء ، لذلك
كنت تغرد عن فقدان
الشهية في الواقع هو الأكثر  شائعة
ولكن هناك أيضًا معلومات جديدة من
منظمة ENT UK في المملكة المتحدة حول
فقدان حاسة الشم وفقدان التذوق
ويمكن أن يكون ذلك في بعض الأحيان مؤشرًا
نعم وهذا أمر رائع لذا فهم
يعودون وينظرون إلى هؤلاء المرضى من
الواضح أن العديد منهم  في الصين في محاولة
لمعرفة كيف بالضبط
تقدمت دوراتهم الدراسية حيث توجد
أعراض أخرى قد تتذكرها في
البداية ، كان هناك اعتقاد بأن هذا
لم يكن كثيرًا في طريق
أعراض الجهاز الهضمي ولكن دراسة
حوالي 200 مريض من أصل  تُظهر الصين
أنه في الواقع لم تكن
أعراض الجهاز الهضمي موجودة فقط في حوالي
نصف المرضى في كثير من الأحيان ، بل كانت أول
أعراض فقدان الشهية في حوالي 84
بالمائة  الإسهال
ألم في البطن يتقيأ من تلك الأنواع من الأعراض ، لذا
فإن الأمر يتعلق قليلاً
بالناس ليقولوا أنه ربما لا
يبدأ هذا دائمًا بحمى أو سعال جاف
أو ضيق في
التنفس ، يمكن أن يبدأ حوالي نصف الوقت مع
الجهاز الهضمي  بعد ذلك ، كما ذكرت
للتو Erica خلال الليل وما يسمى
بفقدان الشم ، والذي يعني في الأساس فقدان
حاسة الشم ، يبدو أنه أحد الأعراض الأخرى التي
يصاب بها العديد من هؤلاء المرضى في كثير من الأحيان ،
ولا يعرفون ما إذا كان مرتبطًا
بجزء فيروس الجهاز التنفسي العلوي من هذا أو
ماذا ولكن في  قد يكون ناس ميا مرتبطًا
بفقدان التذوق وقد يكون مرتبطًا بفقدان
الشهية لسنا متأكدين تمامًا ولكن
من الواضح أنه شيء يجب البحث عنه في
بعض الأحيان ، فإن الأعراض المبكرة ليست
هذه الأعراض الكلاسيكية
مثل هذا الوقت الصعب للكثير منا  في
الخطوة الأولى ، التفكير في الإحساس
بإمكانية التنبؤ ، إحساس بالروتين
نعلم أنه يقلل من الاستجابة للضغط
، وبالتالي حتى إيجاد خطط صغيرة على
مدار اليوم يمكن أن تظل
متسقة من  من اليوم التالي إلى اليوم التالي يمكن أن
يكون مفيدًا حقًا في
مشاهدة نومك مهم جدًا ، فهو
تحت التهديد في الوقت الحالي لأننا قلقون جدًا
ولكن بعد ذلك يكون الأمر بمثابة ضربة مزدوجة
عندما لا نحصل على نوم جيد ، فنحن أكثر
حساسية تجاه التهديدات.  نحن نعلم
أننا نشعر بسوء هواء نقي عندما يكون من
الآمن القيام بذلك ، حتى أجزاء صغيرة من
ضوء الشمس يمكن أن تكون مفيدة للغاية
وبالطبع جزء كبير هو أنك تعلم إبقاء
عقلك نشطًا دون الذهاب إلى
وضع كارثي ، لذا وضع قيود
على وقت بدء المراقبة المتصاعدة
أفكارك التي تعرفها ، حسناً ، هل أجد
معلومات هنا تساعدني على الشعور بمزيد
من التحكم هل اكتسبت البصيرة أم
أنني ألتف حول هذا نوعًا ما
وبدأت في الدوران إلى مكان مظلم حقًا
وأحتاج إلى الرجوع خطوة إلى الوراء
وأنا  أحتاج إلى إعادة ضبط المشهد وتغييره قليلاً
حتى داخل منزلي ،
بالطبع ، أكبر شيء على الإطلاق
الآن أيضًا هو التأكد من
أن التباعد الاجتماعي لا يتحول إلى
عزلة اجتماعية كاملة.  لأننا
نعلم أن له آثارًا خطيرة للغاية على الصحة العقلية
خاصة للأشخاص الذين يشعرون بأنهم
معزولون بشكل خاص عن أحبائهم في الوقت الحالي ، فكيف يتعامل الناس مع ذلك إذا كانوا يشعرون بالعزلة
والوحدة لأنهم بصراحة هم
معزولون ووحيدون ما الذي يجب  إنهم
يفعلون ذلك للمساعدة في التخفيف من ذلك ، نعم
تعلم أنه كان من الصعب رؤية
الناس يبدعون حقًا ، فأنت تعلم
أن قضاء ساعات سعيدة افتراضية في الطهي مع
بعضهم البعض عبر FaceTime مثل دعنا نطبخ
العشاء معًا ، كما تعلمون ، نشاهد الأفلام
معًا قائلين: دعونا نتناول الإفطار
معًا.  الآلات الموسيقية
لبعضهم البعض أو قراءة نفس الكتاب
معًا والتحدث عنه على
الهاتف
بشكل مثير للسخرية ، أعتقد أن أحد الأشياء الإيجابية التي
تعرفها في هذا الرعب الأكبر هو
أن الناس يجب أن يجدوا طرقًا
للالتقاء ولأن الكثير من الناس
محاصرون في المنزل  يكاد يمنحهم
المزيد من الحافز ليقولوا مرحبًا ، أنا حقًا بحاجة إلى
شيء ما هنا
وسأحققه بالطبع ليس كل شيء  منا يمكن أن يفعل
ذلك يعتمد على تقنيتنا ، لكن
حتى أنك تعلم حقًا أن الوصول إلى أحد
الجيران عبر مكالمة هاتفية قديمة الطراز
يمكن أن يكون مفيدًا حقًا في الوقت الحالي ،
وأعتقد أيضًا أنه من المهم أن
يدرك الناس أن هذا أمر
مروع حقًا ، إنه أمر مروع حقًا  حسنًا تمامًا أن
تكون مستاءً وعاطفيًا وخائفًا
في المنزل ، أعني أننا سوف نتغلب
على الأمر الذي ستفعله الولايات
المتحدة ، لكنه صعب ولا يتعين
علينا التظاهر بأنه ليس
نعم ، هذا أمر جيد.  نقطة أعتقد
أن قبول أن بعض القلق في الوقت الحالي أمر
طبيعي للغاية ، فإن ظروفنا ليست
طبيعية ،
لكن رد فعلنا القلق لذلك يمكن أن يكون
طبيعيًا للغاية ، يمكننا تسخير ما يمكننا
إدارته بحيث يمكننا مراقبة أنفسنا
ومحاولة العثور على جيوب من اليوم حيث نحن
أجلس ونتنفس ونقول إن هذا
صعب حقًا هل هناك جزء من
هذا تعلم أنني سأتذكره بطريقة
تساعدني على النمو وأنا أعلم أن هذا يبدو
سخيفًا نوعًا ما عندما نكون قلقين للغاية ولكننا
نفكر  حول كيف يمكننا أن ننظر إلى الوراء في
هذا الأمر وأن نكون الأشخاص الذين نريد أن
نكون في هذه اللحظات يمكن أن يكونوا أقوياء حقًا